[Music]
the future is frightening at least it is
in the tomorrow war
when a group of time travelers appear in
the present to gather allies for a
coming conflict
chris pratt and friends arm up to face
what's coming
here's everything you need to know about
the tomorrow war
the journey of the tomorrow war from
idea to reality began a few years ago
back in mid-february 2019
at the time variety reported that marvel
cinematic universe superstar chris pratt
known to marvel fans everywhere as peter
quill
aka starlord was in talks to team with
director chris mckay for a movie
entitled ghost draft
it was said to be a rousing sci-fi
actioner meant to be released in cinemas
under paramount pictures and skydance
media
the same banner behind the mission
impossible and rebooted star trek
franchises
as well as movies including the
anticipated top gun sequel top gun
maverick
the movie formerly known as ghost draft
was slated to begin production per
variety's 2019 report
sometime in the summer of that year that
didn't end up happening but after a few
months of the film's team rounding out
the cast and settling on a title
principal photography finally kicked off
in september 2019
it's clear that the movie first
announced as ghost draft at some point
got its new title of the tomorrow war
but the minds behind this movie didn't
immediately land on the tomorrow war
when thinking of a new name for the
project
according to the film's lead himself
there were a ton of different title
options tossed around before the
tomorrow war emerged as the winner
on november 9th 2019 chris pratt who
signed on to serve as an executive
producer on the movie in addition to
starring in it took to instagram to
share a snazzy black and white photo
from the set of the film
he announced that ghost draft got a
brand new name offering a rundown of all
the titles that he and the film's team
considered
and apparently a few joke ones for good
measure running down the options pratt
wrote
we went through generation alien world
war a
generation gone saving private ryan
world war z2 but with a's nazis horizon
white spike hero movie brought to you by
verizon
jurassic draft generation draft miller
genuine draft
city slickers alien dawn rapture dawn
apocalypse dawn herodon
destiny war saving tomorrow the tomorrow
war
and that's when it hit me we're calling
it the tomorrow war
for what it's worth we're pretty sure
saving private ryan would have been a
blockbuster hit
with a title locked in and shooting
underway the tomorrow war was on track
for its planned december 25th 2020
release
then a little thing called the covet 19
pandemic happened and the movie's
release date was pushed back
the tomorrow war had reportedly wrapped
principal photography in january 2020
before the pandemic forced both movies
and television shows to suspend
production until further notice
since the movie was reportedly in the
can the delay wasn't an issue of not
having the required footage
but rather that there was no longer a
good time on the horizon to premiere the
movie in theaters
another reason for the tomorrow war
being delayed was because other movies
on paramount and skydance's film
schedule were affected by the
pandemic-induced production shutdowns
those films had to have their release
dates moved so the tomorrow wars release
was put on pause as well as the studios
reassessed their strategies
plus it was april 2020 when paramount
and sky dance executives were making
these decisions to delay films
at the time theaters across the world
were closing indefinitely and many
questioned whether anyone would step
foot into a cinema at all in 2020. on
april 2nd
2020 deadline confirmed that top gun
maverick had been moved to december 23
2020 and the tomorrow war had been
pushed to an undetermined date
top gun maverick ended up moving its
release date again of course
and still isn't out yet but three weeks
after that initial report
variety reported that the tomorrow war
would debut on july 23rd 2021
but more change was on the horizon
the tomorrow war endured being pulled
off the release schedule
and sitting on the shelf for a several
month delay but its journey to the big
screen was thrown even further for a
loop in january 2021
when deadline got word that the film
wouldn't be going to the big screen
at all the outlet reported on january
12th that the major streaming services
of the world had screened the tomorrow
war that weekend a showing likely
motivated by lingering concern
over the safety of seeing films in
theaters and the odds of people showing
up in blockbuster numbers
skydance not paramount was said to have
been pushing to sell the tomorrow war to
a streamer and amazon studios was keen
on picking it up
deadline noted that the company
aggressively offered 200 million dollars
though the deal wasn't set in stone just
yet
it wasn't until april 2021 that
everything was made official and the
tomorrow war was officially a streaming
exclusive
set to hit amazon prime video though not
on july 23rd
as originally expected the tomorrow war
is scheduled to arrive on amazon prime
video on friday july 2nd 2021
just in time for the july 4th holiday
weekend
welcome to earth other than the summer
weather the movie doesn't appear to have
any direct competition on this day when
it comes to similar movies
the boss baby family business universal
pictures follow-up to the 2017 animated
film
the boss baby is launching in theaters
and on the peacock streaming site on
july 2nd as well but there probably
won't be very much
overlap between the people watching the
new boss baby movie and those tuning
into the tomorrow war
the film also doesn't have to worry
about marvel studios long-awaited black
widow stealing its thunder starring
scarlett johansson in her first solo
outing as the character
black widow will open in theaters and be
available to stream on disney plus via
premiere access on july 9th
that gives the tomorrow war a full week
to shine and dominate news headlines
before the mcu movie becomes the talk of
the internet
stop talking listen sorry i mean when
i'm nervous
i talk i'm like 97 on the nervous scale
now since the film is an amazon prime
video exclusive there isn't a very great
chance that the tomorrow war will
receive a second release date on other
video on demand platforms for quite some
time after it's released
if at all if you aren't an amazon prime
subscriber and you've been meaning to
catch up on chris pratt's filmography
you'll want to consider picking up a
subscription
so who's in the tomorrow war anyhow
apart from chris pratt
well let's get the leading man out of
the way first in the tomorrow war chris
pratt plays dan
forrester an army veteran and current
high school teacher who's sent 30 years
into the future to the year 2051
to fight an all-out war against a
mysterious enemy and do his part to save
the world
glo alum betty gilpin plays dan's wife
emmy while ryan kira armstrong portrays
his daughter murray
joining dan on this planet-saving
mission is a brilliant scientist
portrayed by dexter and the handmaid's
tale actress yvonne strahovsky
as well as dan's estranged father played
by oscar-winning actor jk simmons
simmons is coming hot off of the success
of amazon's animated super series
invincible in which he voiced the
super-powered alien nolan grayson aka
omniman the plot of the tomorrow war
is a bit of a unique take on time travel
stories
it follows military veteran and loving
father dan who comes to a child's
birthday party in order to see his
daughter
while watching a live soccer game with
his family a strange event interrupts
the broadcast soldiers from the future
open a portal in the center of the
soccer field
they claim that in 30 years time
humanity will wage a losing war against
an overwhelming alien force
with too few humans left to combat the
force in 2051
soldiers from that time have come to the
year 2021 to conscript people in order
to save the humans of tomorrow
we are fighting a war 30 years in the
future
that's a joke soon after this occurs
people begin getting drafted into what's
known as the
tomorrow war dan's wife emmy is one of
these unlucky few but he volunteers to
go in her stead
fixed with a time traveling device on
his wrist dan and the other soldiers
travel to the future
in order to save the world from a race
of animalistic aliens
speaking of the aliens in the tomorrow
war they're quite
gnarly looking that's thanks to ken
bartelmi the creature designer who
brought the film's extraterrestrial
monsters to life
you may not instantly recognize
bartelmi's name but you've likely
seen his work on the silver screen in
some of the biggest movies of the last
few years
he's worked as a creature designer
character designer or concept artist on
everything from the maze runner movies
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald and detective pikachu to the
predator the nun
and godzilla king of the monsters most
recently bartelli's creature designing
work was on glorious display and 2021's
godzilla vs kong
looking ahead bartelmi will be lending
his talents to the marvel cinematic
universe entry thor love and thunder
and the aquaman sequel aquaman and the
lost kingdom
the trailers for the tomorrow war teased
that the aliens will be fearsome
but viewers will have to wait until the
movie debuts on july 2nd to get the full
scope of just how dangerous they really
are
chatting with variety in a june 2021
interview the tomorrow war writer zac
dean
and star executive producer chris pratt
opened up about the film's themes
dean explained that although it may
appear to be about an ideology or
patriotism or loyalty to protect your
country
it's actually about a very literal
desire to save your own kids
which is what dan's primary motivation
for participating in the tomorrow war is
in other words this whole future war
idea is in service of a very simple
message
as dean put it we're not asking for an
abstract idea
it's about parenting pratt also noted
you are dealing with people who are
making life decisions based
not on the life that they could lead but
rather the world that they're leaving
for their children it's a different
theme to think about someone being
drafted away from their children rather
than children being drafted away from
their parents
as for how dan's relationship with his
estranged father shaped his dynamic with
his own daughter pratt explained that
dan
is blaming his father for all of his
issues pinning everything on his dad not
being around when he was growing up but
when dan comes to realize that he's a
lot like his father things begin to
change for the better
when we look at our parents as these
deities in our life we come to a moment
in our life where we realize oh wow that
was just a kid who had a kid
you realize okay now i'm in the same
dilemma my kids are going to look at me
like i'm some sort of infallible person
and of course i'm not
the only things you need to see the
tomorrow war when it debuts are an
amazon prime account and some time
set aside to stream the movie once it
debuts on july 2nd
but there's a rule that lead actor chris
pratt requests you abide by if you want
to have the best viewing experience
possible
it's simple pretend you're in a movie
theater and turn your phone off
speaking in an interview with digital
spy pratt said you can still have an
amazing viewing experience watching this
on prime i would just advocate that
people turn their phones off
sit down commit to watching all the way
through watch it at home but pretend
you're at the movie theater turn your
phone off and sit
back and enjoy because it's freaking
awesome
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
upcoming movies and tv shows are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]